The question I get asked more than
anything else lately is how can you
possibly say that revenge of the Sith
was a good movie,
but after that,
and I do have my reasons,
the next most asked question is,
who do you trust in the media?
I'm finding this question harder and
harder to answer these days,
which is yet another indication of how
screwed up our political and social
system is right now.
At the same time,
it's hard to know just how screwy our
world is or whether it's just the
loudest and craziest voices that
consistently get amplified on social
media.
Maybe the American revolution actually
was a bit nuttier than the history books
would tell us,
but we'll never know because George
Washington didn't have the chance to
live tweeted without trust.
We really don't have the basic
underpinnings for a free and pluralistic
society.
We have to trust our elected officials,
will do the jobs they're sworn in to do
and carry out the promises they said
they would deliver upon.
We have to trust that our media will
keep the political elite in check and
not just suck up to the powers that be
and we have to trust that our
institutions are strong enough to
withstand corrupt politicians and
totalitarian ideologies that would strip
us from the very freedoms our system was
built upon.
Of course,
trust without doing the necessary work
to make sure it's based in logic and
reason is really just faith.
Having faith that our politicians will
do the right thing or that our media
will hold the politicians to account or
that our system will just function as it
should is basically a recipe for
disaster.
Slowly but surely,
our freedoms will be chipped away at
because faith isn't what guarantees our
freedoms in the first place.
It's the constitution that does so.
Trust is built over time by repeated
evidence that you can actually believe
that when someone says something,
it's what they mean.
You don't believe it's simply because
they say it.
You believe it because of a track record
of a person consistently following
through on their word.
This is the opposite of faith,
which is built on the idea of believing
in something without evidence.
We usually talk about these existential
issues in the context of God and
religion,
but I think it would serve us all well
to ask some important questions about
these issues right here and right now.
So now let me kick the question back to
you.
Who Do you trust in the media?
I'm guessing it's a pretty short list
though.
If you've got some good names,
I'd love to hear them in the comment
section right down below and let's go a
step further with that.
Who Do you trust in politics?
If you're the biggest trump supporter
out there,
do you truly trust everything that he
says or do you accept his untruths
because you believe in his wider agenda.
Accepting the certain amount of untruth
may be the only legitimate way to view
politics and politicians,
but when you add a distrust of the media
to a of politicians and then toss in a
heavy dose of social media craziness,
we ended up with this confused
conversation in which we can't even
agree on basic facts.
This spot where nothing is really true
and what we feel overrides what's
provable is fertile ground for those on
the extremes to take root.
So who do I trust?
Well,
there's a wide range of people from Sam
Harris to Ben Shapiro,
to Larry Elder,
to Eric Weinstein.
Trusting these people doesn't mean that
they're infallible or that I agree with
everything that they say,
but it does mean that I see they have a
commitment to the truth and they've
consistently done their best to put it
out there.
They don't have all the answers and I
certainly don't either,
but I think we're doing our best to find
some truth in the sea of craziness.
For those of us who genuinely want to
figure out how to combat the forces who
want to burn down the system or give
into authoritarian tyranny.
Our work is cut out for us.
As for me,
I trust that it'll work out because I
see more and more of you speaking out
every day.
You might just say that a little faith
in yourself goes a long way.
Joining me this week is a former
candidate for president of the United
States from the Libertarian Party and a
man who,
according to his twitter bio is pro
liberty pro life and Pro Constitution
Austin Petersen.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Hey,
thanks for having me.
We've been trying to do this for quite
some time.
Our twitter.
It's going to go bonkers.
My people love your pupil.
I don't know if you're like me yet,
but I guess the kind of remains to be
seen.
I think they were there.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but there seems to be a classical
liberal,
libertarian little bonding thing
happening in America right now.
People said that if I get you to say
you're a smaller libertarian than that
they're going to donate five bucks.
My Super Pac.
So it's.
Oh,
is that right?
So are you a libertarian?
We can where you can turn some of this
on me at some point,
but not right now yet.
Not yet.
Not just yet.
So,
uh,
so it's funny.
I shooting three shows today and I just
walked outside with my dog just to get
some fresh air.
I just found you wandering in the
street,
you didn't even take a car here.
You're,
you're truly a man of the people.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
from Missouri,
I grew up on a farm.
Pretty common,
you know,
and uh,
I think that um,
you know,
California is beautiful and uh,
we're trying to like be environmentalist
riding bicycles.
So I just want to walk and found your
studio.
Yeah.
All right,
so here we are.
There's a lot I want to get to with you,
but let's just start with the basics.
People know,
I like definitions.
You ran as a libertarian,
what is a libertarian to you will
essentially libertarian.
It allows you to choose your own values
as long as you don't try and use the
government to force those values on
somebody else.
That's why we get a lot of infighting in
the Libertarian party because we have so
many people from so many different
backgrounds with different values.
But the one value we all share is that
we believe that government should be
limited so that individuals can choose
what they want to do and,
and choose their values.
And,
and explore the wide range of options,
you know,
sometimes those options are dangerous,
some people choose to smoke,
but they should have the right to do
that as long as they don't try and
impose a cost on others.
Right.
And,
and so as soon as you start talking
about what sort of cost people are
imposing on others,
that's when government starts to come
into the equation,
you know,
at the most hardcore end of
libertarianism,
which some say a is the true
libertarianism is it's anarchy.
And our coo capitalism,
I think I fall right before that.
I train right there and I,
I call myself a min,
darkest.
Essentially the government should be
relegated very basic rules.
They should protect life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
You know,
that may include things like fire
courts,
police,
military,
otherwise the,
everything else should be solved by the
market.
Yeah.
So I had a Brian Caplan from George
Mason University who's in an narco
capital verlander co,
capital Arco for some reason.
Yeah.
Brilliant guy and I thoroughly.
We did about an hour and a half.
I enjoyed every minute of it.
There were moments where I thought,
all right,
this is a bit much know some private
court stuff and some of the passivism
stuff and open borders,
but is that the inherent problem with
the Libertarian Party?
Not The philosophy,
but the party that this thing is really
wide and when you say I'm a libertarian,
people see some of these guys or some of
the,
you know,
at the convention,
that guy running around without a shirt
and some of them were crazy pieces.
That was the worst thing that happened
to get to that in a second,
but that it's bad because it's based on
the individual.
It's hard to get a whole bunch of
individually focused people to agree on
something because essentially you're
talking about taking collective action,
right?
Yeah.
This is kind of anathema to the
libertarian cause,
but I mean the Libertarian party is made
up of sincere individuals.
These people really want limited
government.
A lot of these people are victims of the
state of people that have been harmed,
whether they've been persecuted in their
communities for doing things like
homeschooling or maybe they want to
drink raw milk,
right?
Maybe they want to have the ability to
sell that,
right?
Amish farmers and things like that.
So it's,
it's kind of easy to poke fun at the
people like the naked guy,
but,
but the thing is,
is that the news often doesn't go in and
cover the tales of the single mothers
who are being harmed because their,
their tax rates are so high that it's
hard for them to feed their kids.
Right?
That doesn't make as compelling a new
story as the guy who,
you know,
dances around.
So,
so there,
the problem is,
is that we're missing the forest for the
trees in some sense.
And there are a lot of sincere dedicated
activists and Libertarian party who
really just want to.
They're not just fighting for their own
freedom and many of them,
many of them are sincere patriots who
are fighting for the freedom of their
fellow countrymen and they just see the
two parties as being one in the same in
some sense that they really.
That their solutions are just more
government.
So that's what,
that's,
that's the kind of the untold story of
the heroes of the Libertarian party,
which we don't see very often.
Right.
Okay.
So I want to spend most of our time
talking about looking forward,
but we do have to look back a little bit
here.
Right?
I mean,
to me 2016 was a massive disaster for
you guys because
I,
I've said this a billion times.
First off I voted for Gary.
Okay.
I've had Gary Johnson on the show.
The candidacy ultimately was just
terrible and I think if there was ever a
year where the libertarians or any
third,
maybe the Greens,
whoever,
although obviously I agree more with you
guys.
Uh,
but if there was ever a year where there
was going to be a mark made,
not,
not the presidency,
but a mark to be made.
This was it.
There was so much discussed with trump
and Clinton.
What happened?
I'll tell you this topic,
I mean,
this turns me into Salt Bay,
like,
but um,
don't you usually walk around with a
musket,
couldn't make the,
uh,
the far the flintlock right?
Yeah.
The stuff,
boy,
you're going to get my hackles up.
Alright.
So it's very difficult to be in this
situation.
We're in the position of having tried to
stop that right now having kind of seen
it.
There's nothing more frustrating and I
think a lot of libertarian see this in
so many other ways on society as a whole
where we see things kind of rushing
toward a cliff and you're screaming
stop.
And people,
if you're going to tell people the
truth,
you better make them laugh or else
they'll kill you.
A and a that's happening in society.
But with the Libertarian party,
there were so many times when the
account at the incompetence was being
displayed pre-primary and people either
weren't paying attention or they were
applauding it.
Uh,
I mean there's videos of some of the
gaps and stumbles and one on before the
convention.
And I don't think there's any excuse.
I mean the people who take
responsibility for what it was need to
take responsibility because they had
every opportunity to try and stop it and
they sort of cheered it on.
But you know,
the Libertarian party has a lot of the
same problems that the major two party
has with cults of personality and things
like that and with none of the upsides
of actually winning elections.
So that's the problems of,
of fighting a in a third party.
But
is there a bigger issue here,
which is that for the specific stumbles
that Gary made once he got the
nomination,
and again I liked him as a person,
I think he's a decent guy and I hope
you'll come back here and I'd be happy
to discuss all this stuff with him.
Um,
but he's,
that the bigger issue,
the only time anyone ever talked about
the libertarians was when he either made
a gaff or when the naked guy ran round
beyond that,
there was virtually no coverage.
So it was almost as if you had to do
outlandish things.
So I watched the libertarian debates and
I thought they needed to say more crazy
things if anyone was going to pay
attention as even though I don't believe
that generally related to to
politics,
it's not about what you say,
it's about how you say it very
frequently.
Right.
And so sometimes it was just Gary's
delivery that came off as awkward.
It wasn't necessarily what he was
saying,
but the way that he was saying it,
which I think puts people off.
Uh,
and the thing about Donald trump that I
think was so attractive was that he was
giving the last year was a crazy bastard
year.
Right?
And,
and libertarians,
that's crazy bastards.
That could have been our year.
Yeah.
Uh,
and you know,
with the rise of the alt right,
which is really what propelled in many
ways helped propel donald to the
presidency.
A lot of those people,
you know,
were sincere conservatives who were
looking for a,
a third option,
a,
they wanted somebody who could take down
Hillary.
And I think that the real strategy
problem was simply that it looked as if
gary and bill were sort of cozying up to
Hillary,
which is what nobody in the United
States wanted because they rejected her.
So it wasn't so much what Gary was
saying,
it was,
it was relied a little bit more on
tactics.
I mean,
yeah,
the delivery was not that good,
but.
And the gas were horrible,
but it,
it really just comes down to not being
able to read the political winds of the,
of the time.
And that's really where we suffered.
Yeah.
Without getting too thick in the weeds
on just the machinations behind the
scene of the party,
because I don't think people really
understand like what happens by the
party.
So we know the Democrats have this
massive machine.
We know it's deeply corrupt and that was
a lot of that has been exposed.
The Republicans also have a pretty
powerful machine.
I don't think it's quite as corrupt,
but who knows what is,
what is the underpinnings of the
libertarian machine,
like what's going on behind the scenes?
Who's in charge?
What?
Nobody.
Anarchy,
right.
I mean,
they have the Libertarian National
Committee,
their job is to run candidates for
office.
Um,
the.
I think the good thing about the
Libertarian party is that anybody can
participate,
right?
They sound like a Democrat,
so they have super delegates and things
like that.
I mean anybody can become a delegate if
you joined the Libertarian Party and go
to your state convention.
So the way that the Libertarian party
works is it's powered by the people
there,
there isn't,
you know,
some shadowy Koch money,
the Koch brothers left years ago.
So it's really just powered by the
activist and the people who want to try
and see these ideas be put into public
policy.
Now there are some people who actually,
they,
they caucus with the party,
but they don't want the party to
actually win elections for,
for multitudes of reasons.
One being perhaps that they think that
there'll be a system wide collapsed and
libertarians will get blamed for it if
some,
if there was a libertarian president and
another one is that they think that the
parties should be educational.
So you've got all these different
factions in the party,
uh,
and,
and some of them are sincere and
committed activists who really want to
bring about change,
but the,
but when it comes to the machinations,
it's what you see for the most part is
what you get.
I mean,
there are some backroom dealings and
things that go on and so a lot of
pressure and hassling that goes onto the
convention.
People Endorse Bill Weld will give you
the world.
It's like that story in the Bible where
like they take juices and Satan is like,
if you will bow before me and I know
bill well,
but,
um,
but you know,
there's,
that kind of stuff happens.
But for the most part it's what you see
is what you get.
Was there a moment a after Gary got the
nomination that you would have
considered being his vp or did they
announce once he got the nomination,
did they say they were a team
immediately?
Of course.
So he was running to be the VP.
And um,
the thing was this,
you know,
my mistakes that I made at the
convention was that I actually took the
principal,
moves over the pragmatic moves and I'll
just explain this very briefly.
So there was a brief period of time when
some people said,
Okay Austin,
if you want just go run for the VP slot.
But because I was trying to think for
what the good of the party and for the
good of the ticket,
I thought to myself,
okay,
well Gary hates me and I wouldn't want
to be hamstrung by a VP that I can't
stand.
And he obviously wanted bill,
you know,
the delegates thought that he was
better.
So I was trying to,
I,
I gave into the will of the majority and
I thought,
no,
I'm not going to do this because I think
it's going to cripple the ticket.
Well then later,
I stupidly,
I didn't realize that Gary had
threatened that if he didn't get bill
weld,
he would quit.
So if I had been the VP then I would
have been a candidate if gary had quit.
So maybe I should have just stuck it.
Dual.
I suspect he wouldn't have chose you
though.
No,
but they choose.
That's how the Libertarian party is
different from the major two parties.
The delegates choose the vice
presidential candidate.
So if I really wanted to be a bug chunk,
I could've,
I could've taken my gun out of the trash
and mounted a campaign to try and be the
VP pick with the hopes that Gary would
quit.
But that's just being again,
a jerk.
I already have been labeled a jerk so
I'm trying to get away from them.
So my last question to you at the end of
this is going to be about 20,
20,
but,
but as a lead into that then,
so you learned that lesson there.
So do you think you would do things
differently next time before you even
tell me if 20,
20 is an option?
Yes,
I would definitely do things
differently.
And uh,
you know,
there are certain things that you
learned from the process,
you know,
hindsight is 20 slash 20.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think that tactically I made some
mistakes but print from a principal
perspective,
I did everything right,
raised money,
the grassroots way online,
you know,
just doing live streams and going around
the country.
I think we raised $120,000,
so,
so in,
in a lot of ways,
my campaign pioneered many of the
campaigns in the future for people who
have no power,
right?
People who are grassroots who can come
out of nowhere and I think I showed that
people who are sincere committed
activists can,
can do that.
So there are some things that I would do
differently,
but most of it's just sort of
parliamentary procedure things.
How much for you as an outsider running
on an outsider,
a ticket,
uh,
was about raising money because that to
me is the root of all the problems right
now.
Well,
you know what,
the funny thing was was that I found
about raising money is that when things
are good and you're happy and you're
doing well,
you know,
people will send you money.
But there's nothing that raises money
like controversy.
And one thing that happened to me,
and it's so ironic because I was just
their keynote speaker this year,
now,
the Colorado Libertarian Party
disinvited me from their debate and I
was in Illinois at the time and I'm
there with my,
my staff.
And they said,
okay,
well you're not invited because I
disagree with some of the radical
anarchists on one of their base
philosophical principles.
So they're like,
oh,
you're not libertarian,
you're not invited.
What principle is,
it's called the,
the nap,
the nonaggression principle.
Uh,
which many libertarians believe that is
the centerpiece of libertarian
philosophy,
which I in no uncertain terms completely
reject simply because in my mind,
I believe it leads one to a form,
a strict form of pacifism,
which,
which doesn't account for self defense,
which they,
they dispute,
uh,
but aggression being a sort of a,
a term that can be broadly used in many
ways.
Like what do you different define as
aggression?
It leads one to consider.
Maybe we will need a court system to
Suss it out,
which would imply a government which
would end the argument for anarchy,
right?
They have gotten,
they disagree and they're going to be
very mad at me for saying that,
but so you're taking in that specific
and what you would argue is just a more
realistic approach or a more functional
approach.
Not really.
It's not a matter of realism.
Essentially.
It's a matter of,
of real true principle simply because
many people have argued,
and boy,
this is going to make people mad,
but,
uh,
in the end,
the concept of we're putting this on
youtube and youtube comments or anything
but lovely liberal friends are gonna
like it kind of a heretic in libertarian
circles for this,
but simply many libertarians have argued
and many have told me directly to my
face that the evil of government is,
is so horrible that it's better that we
have a society where it may be immoral
to allow a child to starve to death,
but it's not illegal simply because it's
all about the initiation of force.
Right?
And I like to play the,
the,
um,
the puzzle game.
You know,
if you walk past a homeless person on
the street,
they're starving to death and you don't
feed them.
Have you committed a crime?
No.
Have you initiated force?
If you have a child and it's your child
and by neglect you allow that child to
starve to death.
Have you committed a crime?
Yes.
Have you initiated force know so that
that's really where it comes down to it.
The rights of children is,
is sort of where we start talking about
whether or not some third party may have
a right to come in,
but that controversy was enough to make
the libertarian part of Colorado say no,
and it made my activist so angry that
they started pouring money my coffers
saying Austin drive to Colorado right
now and we drove all night.
Thirteen hours straight to the
convention,
took second place.
You know,
beat up on Gary a little bit and raise
money so that.
That's fascinating because this
infighting of all the parties I find
incredible.
Like just the inability for anyone to
build a bridge these days,
which is so much of what I'm.
I'm not a political insider,
but what I'm trying to do around here is
build some bridges and show people you
can disagree on abortion and we'll talk
about that in a little bit and a bunch
of different things and still find some
basic principles to believe in.
But let's just talk about the general
role of government because that's really
what this all comes down to.
So you touched on it just a little bit
up top.
Give me the basic things that you
believe government should exist for the
specifics,
not just,
not just the ideas of liberty and that
sort of thing.
So the libertarianism isn't really about
government,
it's about self government.
So that's the concept that,
that,
uh,
you and if you have a,
just,
if you have a moral just society,
then people should be self-governed.
Uh,
and uh,
so it,
it's different from the sort of FDR
definition of freedom because FDR and
the Social Democrats believe that
freedom means freedom from want.
So you're not free if you're hungry,
that's their,
their definition.
So the question really comes down to is,
is that we as Libertarians have a
different concept of freedom from most
people because our concept of freedom is
the most politically incorrect because
it requires personal responsibility and
when you start telling talking to people
about personal responsibility,
that's when I get angry because as the,
and even libertarians aren't perfect
when it comes down to this,
but when,
when it comes to the actual role of
government,
it should be the absolute minimum that
is required in order to sustain life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
That's the declaration of independence.
That's not the law,
but the constitution being the law,
it has very specific enumerated powers
as sometimes conservatives I think make
a mistake where they'll say,
well,
we believe in states rights,
and the Libertarian says,
no,
actually that's a misnomer.
Only people have rights.
You know,
states have powers and the idea is that
those powers should be strictly limited
and enumerated.
So we delegate some of our,
some of our power to government,
but we don't delegate and have our
rights to government.
Our rights are intrinsic or rights are
natural.
They are self evident as to our
humanity,
and so libertarians simply believe that
the individual should be self govern and
governed to is to the greatest extent
possible until that self governance is a
problem,
right?
If you do not police yourself,
you will be policed.
So in or so as long as I'm,
you know,
whatever action that you're taking
isn't,
it created some negative externality on
the community in that question,
you know,
when it comes to the environment,
right?
What are the,
you may be polluting or something like
that.
These were problems with libertarians
face,
we believe in a strict definition of
property rights.
So essentially what government should do
is it should,
you know,
adjudicate disputes between property
rights holders and it should prosecute
criminal cases of force and fraud really
is what it should do.
And that's really the limited role of
government.
So you would take like sanitation away
from the government,
you would take the US Postal Service.
All of those kinds of things were easy
where we're keeping courts where we're
keeping a cops and then nuclear weapons
in my opinion.
But yeah,
but,
but that's cops,
courts nukes.
Yeah,
cops,
courts have nukes.
Well,
I think we just came up with your slogan
for a couple different way.
If I ever write a police.
Yeah.
How is any of this different or do you
consider yourself an objectivist?
Actually,
I mean,
I flirt with them now.
Can really get you in trouble because I
know you mentioned Iran.
People go nuts.
I like a lot of it and I've had many
people,
uh,
your own Brooke who is books right over
there.
I think that she,
she rejects altruism.
I get a joy out of doing something.
I know she,
the argument is that,
well,
if you get a joy out of doing it for
other good people,
then it's selfish,
but it's not entirely selfish.
I mean,
I,
I think that,
um,
you know,
that there is a,
there is a desire for us to sacrifice
ourselves in order to do it for the
greater good.
Some people think that the government
should require that sacrifice on.
It's like mandatory service.
But as a libertarian,
I believe in voluntary service,
a voluntary military.
And if I were to,
if I had served in the military,
I would be doing it out of a sense of
patriotism,
which would be,
in some sense,
a sense of selflessness.
I think many people have been drafted,
right?
But a lot of people who fought in world
war against the Nazis were doing it
because they were fighting for their
family and they were fighting out of a
greater sense of oneself.
I mean,
sometimes libertarians,
I think objectives are sort of immune to
that,
but,
but not all libertarians are.
Some Libertarians do what they do out of
the,
out of the sense of what's good for the
community.
Um,
I,
uh,
maybe,
maybe this is what I would say was
selfish,
but I actually do want to see humanity
flourish and thrive.
I just simply don't believe that
government is the best way for us to do
that.
Yeah.
So I don't see actually a major
distinction there from,
from what you would believe,
as opposed to an objectivist because
doing for yourself what is selfishly
good.
I always view that as,
that's not necessarily gonna hurt your
neighbor because if you're smart and
you're doing what's good for you,
you're not going to be dumping in your
neighbor's lawn because you want your
neighbor to be happy too.
So like sometimes don't you just do good
thing for people even though it doesn't
benefit you.
I mean,
yeah,
it may make you feel good,
but every once in a while I catch myself
just doing things for people like
opening a door,
handing a quarter to a homeless person,
right?
Somebody my phone to use or something
like that.
Just not big.
And like sometimes I don't derive any
pleasure from it.
I just do it automatically.
So then that,
then we're on the philosophical piece of
it.
Is that somehow actually for you,
which it almost to me it's almost
irrelevant in a sort of real world.
Right?
That's probably my biggest issue with
objectivist is just simply the,
the again,
that it's distasteful to me because I
really disliked called some personality,
right?
And uh,
and I just,
I'm,
I'm a contrarian and a skeptic and I
just really like to pick things apart,
find the flaws in it,
you know,
this is what gets you in trouble and it
gets you branded a heretic,
but you know,
when you find flaws and you want to pull
the thread,
eventually sweater comes apart just
because I like to see what things are
made of.
Right.
And I don't like to accept things just
because this Marie Rothbart,
senator Iran set it right.
Or Ron Paul said it,
you know,
now it just angered the.
Everybody else appreciate.
I normally don't have a list of people
to anger,
but I feel like I should have had a
little Glen Beck whiteboard here and I
could just knock it all.
We haven't,
we haven't hit feminists,
sjws patients.
Patients will get there.
Okay.
So we've taken back a lot of this stuff
with government.
We've taken back all of those things.
Do you think that's actually possible?
Like is that the government too big at
this point and our people to dumb down
to understand why big government is in
important.
So for example,
when I hear a lot of progressive saying,
you know that it just the government
should redistribute and all of these
government programs and they get upset
when we cut money to the arts.
I don't think that's going to stop art
and I think it actually might help art
that,
but we've just become so numb to how
things work that if you were to try to
reverse some of this stuff,
you might do some really irreparable
damage in ways that maybe we can't even
see.
Well,
at the risk of sounding like a founding
father,
I'm going to call Tj and say,
and we should've been doing this.
The natural tendency is for government
to grow in liberty to shrink.
So do I think we can go back?
I think we can.
The only problem is,
is that we have to adopt,
not the,
not the principles,
but the tactics of some of our opponents
were the Fabian Socialists who want to
try and grow government bit by bit is
we're going to have to try and fight a
war game of inches.
Right?
And we're going to have to take ground
bit by bit,
so I do think that we can go back.
But the problem is,
is that with,
with my movement,
the Liberty Movement is that we're not
content with small games,
right?
We want to see big games.
We want to start seeing major victories
because we see our opponents getting
major victories all the time and I think
we've got to be a little bit more
patient.
We've got to fight,
you know,
on the short game before we can worry
about the long game in some ways.
Why doesn't the party do anything down
ticket?
Why is it that you only hear about
libertarians come national election time
and as far as I know there is.
Are there any,
there must be some randomly avowed
libertarians in there.
It's just that we,
we sort of.
There's not a lot of incentives because
when you run as a like a senator or a
president as a libertarian a,
you're,
you're going to get the same amount of
hell that you're going to get if you run
for lower office.
But at least there's the benefit of
getting a little bit of notoriety,
right?
A little bit of fame,
perhaps a little bit of opportunity to
advance your ideas.
I mean,
when you're running for the,
for the dog catcher as a libertarian,
you're going to get the same amount of
hell,
but it's your neighbor next door that is
going to give it to you.
So I think that the incentives are
probably,
you know,
messed up there.
And also we just,
um,
I think there's just a lot of people
don't know what it means to be a
libertarian.
A lot of people who will,
you know,
Bill Maher says he's a libertarian,
right?
And uh,
what's the guy,
the,
uh,
John Bolton Ambassador,
John Bolton came on my show once and was
like,
I'm a libertarian,
really invade Russia because actually
he,
I think of it more as a neocon a well
to,
to some neo constant,
this is going to make more people angry.
But here's some neo-cons they actually
consider themselves anarchists in a
sense,
no borders,
right?
And that if we see somebody,
uh,
if we,
if we see somebody like a genocide going
on overseas and things like that,
Wellesley,
if we believe in a borderless world and
these are all humans members of the
human race,
why should we not intervene overseas?
I mean a lot of Democrats agree with
that,
right?
That we should be stepping into Darfur
in Sudan and Yemen and,
and we should be,
you know,
having humanitarian interventions around
the world.
And so the neoconservatives in some ways
think of themselves as libertarian
humanitarians and in some way because by
bringing democracy to the Middle East,
they are spreading freedom around the
world.
And that's their thought.
The only problem is,
is that you buy in using government for
this,
you know,
they,
they're,
they're ends,
may be positive,
but the means that they,
that they use end up,
you know,
with the destruction of regimes and with
humanitarian crisis.
So what do,
what would your position beyond that
that I know that obviously you wouldn't
be for nation building,
but in the case of a,
of a true genocide or a case of what's
happening in Syria now?
I think the general libertarian ideas
thought of as isolationists,
where do you fall in some sense the,
the,
some of the returns are isolationists
actually many of the,
that's more of a Paleo conservative
thing that people who want to build a
wall on the southern border,
right?
And they want to stop trade overseas.
Those are,
those people are much more isolationist.
But,
um,
uh,
there,
there are ways to solve these problems
and if you're going to use government to
solve foreign policy problems,
you should use the constitution.
That's really what it is.
And,
and the problem is,
is that we ignore the constitution.
The constitution actually gives.
And Libertarians don't talk this up
enough.
The constitution does give the congress
some authorization to act in a manner
that would make liberals very angry,
which is that it would allow the
congress to lay a letter of mark and
reprisal.
The last time they did that was the war
of 1812.
So international laws and norms have
changed.
So,
um,
if it's a,
if it's a terrorist activity,
essentially it would be something
similar to how you,
uh,
how we dealt with a Sama bin Ladin
because we have such a deep and profound
sense of patriotism.
United States.
We think only the government can kill
terrorists,
were not willing to get go all 1776 on
that bus and higher a higher merck,
which is really what we're talking about
here.
So in a case like that,
like I've been lied in type case,
you would actually be for that you hire,
you're basically subcontracting
contracting our army out and it's
probably,
you would argue,
I assume be would be a cheaper and more
effective way to Ron Paul after nine
slash 11 actually introduced legislation
to,
uh,
to go into kill bin Laden using letters
of mark and reprisal because at least
we're following constitutional due
processes.
A lot of libertarians,
uh,
that,
um,
that don't agree with the authorization
for the use of military force have to
admit that that was quote unquote a
congressional authorization.
And,
and the real problem that we were
dealing with in terms of law of the laws
of war or that if we declare war on isis
in some sense,
if we lose,
we're legitimising them as a state actor
and in some ways we don't want to do
that.
So in order for us to behave in a manner
that,
uh,
that is in conduct with constitutional
principles,
reviving Article One,
section eight,
and the letters of mark is a way for us
to follow constitutional processes.
But the problem is,
is that liberals aren't going to like
this because if we're talking about
privatizing the military and the
Conservatives aren't going to like it
because it's not the whole bad ass team.
America,
hail team six,
kill them.
But we have the,
we've got thousands of former veterans
who are out of work who would love to do
the United States a favor.
And if you gave them a contract,
one of the beautiful things about it is
only libertarians are going to like
this,
is that any bounty that they capture
over there can be brought back and sold
to the United States.
So all of those guns that fell into the
hands of Isis can come back and be sold,
not in California where I'm from.
You could have a beautiful new military
grade weapon.
So when I hear you talk about this now,
but I can go there intellectually with
you for sure.
And I like the idea is that this,
and especially if you route things in
the constitution.
Uh,
I love that.
When I hear you say this though,
there's a piece of me going,
this sounds like Rambo or you know,
it just sounds like some eighties movies
were still owner in where they got a
bunch of mercenary.
I'm pretty sure this was a movie.
Was this partly the rock?
They get a bunch of disgruntled former
military men.
They come together and they find the
guy.
I think Predator was sort of about this
too.
There's an alien that you're going to
hunt.
Right?
Right.
But the idea of that,
that just sounds crazy to people.
I'm not saying to you it's crazy,
but just so how do you even get there?
Well,
new ideas or they always sound crazy,
right?
Like legalizing marijuana 30,
40 years ago,
you're crazy,
you're stupid,
you're a stoner,
blah,
and now we see that things start to
change.
Right?
And you know,
crazy people.
Like the problem with this is,
is that is that there's this really
great quote where somebody used the
other day on twitter,
they said that I'm a smart people sound
like crazy people to stupid people.
So.
So the problem may not be that just
because I'm an opinion is in the
minority.
That's wrong,
right?
Most of the time whenever people are
like,
oh,
you're crazy,
nobody agrees with you.
Well you know,
maybe most people are kind of stupid,
so maybe you're the crazy ones and the
media is not helping that.
At some point you've got to be willing
to put your foot in the ground and take
a stand and say,
I don't care if nobody agrees with me.
I'm going to take a stand on principle
and listen to the founding fathers did
not put this into the constitution for
no reason.
You know why they did this?
It's because the war of 1776 was
primarily one on the seas by private
mariners.
There was no continental navy.
There was something like maybe six or
seven ships.
There were over a thousand,
uh,
who,
people who turned their merchant mariner
ships into dogs of war.
I mean,
this is the days of fighting sale,
but I mean it without those merchant
mariners turned a private tiers,
we would not have won our war of
independence.
They captured hundreds of British ships.
So I mean,
when,
when the going gets tough,
sometimes you have to turn to the
private market to solve these things.
But again,
the reason why it's distasteful to the
establishment is for two different
reasons that conservatives love it.
They're like,
oh,
this is a great idea,
but we'll never get the liberals on
board.
And we'd much rather trust it to our,
our Navy,
Navy seal team guys.
And the liberals are like,
oh my God,
you're privatizing war.
I mean,
you know,
it's horrible.
It's the free market and it's war.
So it's very hard to win that battle.
But I mean,
whatever I do,
I try and couch it in actual precedent
law,
the law,
the constitution,
that way I think you remained consistent
and uh,
you know,
again,
new ideas are always sound crazy until
they finally become accepted.
Yeah.
So speaking of precedent and the
constitution,
what do you think of the general state
of the Constitution right now?
I think it's a pretty beautiful,
almost perfect document to be governed
by,
but it doesn't seem to be what we're
really governed by anymore.
It's being trampled in every direction
right now.
You can make cases that trump's
trampling it in certain ways with
executive actions.
And by the way,
Obama did plenty of them and George W
dot Bush did plenty of them.
So that's a non partisan attack.
We also don't,
you know,
we do military actions where we don't
get congressional authorization.
What was Libya where they call it a
Connecticut military action or they just
make up terms and you go,
oh,
that's not a war.
I'm pretty sure if Libya had been
blowing us a bar,
we'd call it a war.
Um,
so the general state of how we are,
are,
or are not governed by the constitution
in many ways.
I think we're living in a post
constitutional republic,
you know,
has some of the trappings of a
constitutional republic.
And you know,
the,
the good thing is,
is that the bill of rights still exists.
It's still enforced.
I mean,
Congress uses the fifth amendment all
the time.
They've got people in there,
in the hearings that are always having
to plead the fifth.
That's a big one,
right?
And then they of course,
the,
uh,
the supreme court relies on the second
amendment when it upholds decisions in
like Heller or,
or McDonald versus Chicago.
So,
so you've got the second amendment.
I don't think anybody would know,
maybe some people would like to get rid
of it,
but I thought,
yeah,
there's,
there's plenty of.
But,
but most people,
I think cooler heads will prevail on
that issue.
You've got the first amendment,
which is in retreat in a lot of ways.
College campuses,
probably primarily the spots where
they're in retreat.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
it's also a retreat in some ways in the
mainstream media.
This is why,
you know,
the Rubin report is probably so popular
and successful,
not just because you're so tremendously
talented,
but because,
but because people are seeking out
alternate means of information,
um,
you know,
we don't live in,
in North Korea,
so I can't say that the constitution has
been a total failure,
but I do think that in some ways the
constitution was far from perfect.
I'm the founders tried to get rid of
slavery,
uh,
at the signing of the declaration of
independence.
It didn't happen.
It took another 100 years and a bloody
civil war.
So,
so there were some institutional
problems with the,
the uh,
constitution.
And we've had a,
we had to pass the 13th and the 14th
amendment.
Yeah.
And again,
it took a war for that.
Um,
but,
uh,
I think that,
you know,
if you look at postwar amendments,
you of course you've got things like,
um,
uh,
you've got the 16th and the 17th
amendments,
which have been the most anti
libertarian parts of the constitution.
Now we have a law by bureaucracy,
right?
So,
so in many times the things like the FDA
or the EPA,
they'll,
they'll write law and enforce it and
that was,
that was definitely alien to the concept
of constitutional law is written by the
founders.
So with,
with,
if you're going to have a bureaucracy
then I think the bureaucracy should be
limited to operating within
constitutional law,
but if they're to going to,
you know,
create laws and those laws should have
to be passed by Congress and they,
those laws or regulations in many ways.
So that's really where the problem comes
is with all the executive branch
agencies that have been created that
are,
that I think are probably the biggest
problem that we have for the record.
I didn't mean that,
that,
that in and of itself it's perfect,
but in terms of the way that we can be
governed as we humans are the ones that
write this evidence,
it's pretty close.
The best we've got because we've got a
CNA and we are flawed things that create
these things.
So as perfect as maybe we can create,
but of course just a,
as a,
as an independent thing.
The thing though is that,
uh,
for some reason the founders didn't
build a wall along the southern border
so that,
that can be improved upon because at the
time they would have been no need for a
casino down there.
All right.
So you mentioned the EPA.
So the,
the two ones that I hear all the tie or
the fruit of drug administration,
these are the two that you hear when
people say Libertarians are nuts.
Even Bill Maher,
who I know he half now identify as
libertarian,
but he's for a lot of big government
stuff at the same time.
Uh,
you know,
I saw a couple weeks ago he said
something about that trump got rid of
this thing with the EPA and now they're
going to start jumping in rivers again,
is immediately what he said.
And to me it's like we now live in 2017
where everyone has a phone and if the
company a block away from his dumping in
the river or the smokes coming out of
their chimney or that everyone would
report on everyone,
that's another problem that society has
altogether.
Um,
but that we would police ourselves in a
way and as John Stossel who I love would
always say,
you know,
the more regulations we keep putting in
companies,
just figuring out other ways to do it,
we just keep putting money in lawyers
pockets and we're not actually
accomplishing anything.
We're just shifting around bullshit
basically all over the place.
Um,
so I can jump in on.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
So,
so two things.
There's EPA and then there's the FDA.
So very briefly with the EPA,
the EPA was created by Nixon.
It was created to essentially offer
scientific information in court cases
where our property rights were in
dispute.
So the original idea behind the EPA is a
good one because,
you know,
Congress is a,
is not made up entirely of scientists,
right?
It's mostly lawyers and lawyers aren't
environmental scientists.
And so you're going to need the
testimony of environmental scientists
are going to need someone to actually go
out and do the research,
find the samples and prove perhaps that
some company is putting too much mercury
or some sort of toxin into the,
into the environment.
You're going to need science for that
specifically.
Not Be political though,
right?
Not Be political.
Right.
And not to be the enforcement arm.
Right?
Because right now there are a bunch of
ventilated bureaucrats with assault
rifles.
Right.
You've got the EPA,
I think the US Department of Agriculture
has sub machine guns right there.
That.
Right.
So they're checking the cows,
you know,
there's a.
When it comes to the FDA,
I actually think the FDA is an easier
case to make for the case of abolishment
because even though people think,
oh my gosh,
well it's the things that we eat all the
time.
I'm like,
yeah,
actually.
And if you haven't noticed,
people are much more conscious about
what they eat.
And uh,
you know,
whenever I look at yelp reviews,
perfect example,
every time you go and eat somewhere,
I go and eat somewhere.
If I've never been there before,
I checked the opera and if they're like,
it's dirty,
it's got cockroaches,
you know,
terrible service,
I don't go there.
And,
and that,
that's a market mechanism,
that's a regulation,
right?
It's a free market regulation that
people use in order to determine whether
or not they should eat somewhere.
I mean,
it doesn't take very long to figure out
that,
you know,
some,
some food sources bad,
but the problem is,
is that when anybody makes a mistake,
which they do,
even the government can't even stop some
of Salmonella from getting out.
It happens whenever somebody's child
dies,
you know,
they say,
well,
one death is too many.
Let's create an enormous,
a government institution for the
children and we'll save all the kitties.
And if you don't do this,
then you hate children and you want all
the children to die.
And that's why we have these
institutions.
Because as a politician,
it's so much easier to say,
well,
I'm for the children.
I'm for checking children's food and we
don't want them putting poison and
baby's milk.
Right?
Because yeah,
because people really have an incentive
to poison right these milk,
right?
Because actually if you are a good
producer of food and you create clean,
healthy food,
you make more money,
whole foods,
they are making much more than the lower
end retail chains.
So I just walk in there and hand them
all my cash because I'm like,
I know I'm not walking out of here with
any money.
It in some sense it's elitist and
because.
Because what they'll do is the people
who argue for it will say,
Oh,
well I'm not worried about me.
Right?
It's not me.
I can.
I'm wealthy enough to check my food.
Like I have no problem with it.
Like if I had a private agency that was,
you know,
checking the food and had a stamp on it,
like I would be fine,
but it's all the underclass,
right?
Is the plebes that we need someone to
take care of them.
Right.
And it becomes a very elitist thing that
we need to have the government because
we,
we need to have the really,
really smart people like about 100 or
two to two to 300 of them sitting in,
sitting in a room making these decisions
for the Plebes,
you know.
And that's,
and that's what it comes down to is very
paternalistic.
I never thought of it in,
in the whole foods concept.
But there is something really there
because you know,
if you go to whole foods,
at least the one over here,
they've got,
you know,
five levels of how they treat the
animal.
And one of the lowest is like free
range,
which is still pretty damn good.
The highest.
It's like they took them out to dinner
before and they drug them and yeah,
that sounded weird.
But that,
that's all done by whole foods.
It's by their policy.
Right.
But,
but,
but what,
but if they don't do it at Walmart,
you see the good and then the
paternalistic cake like,
but they don't do that at Walmart.
Well you don't shop at Walmart.
Well,
well,
but,
but other people do.
And I care about them.
No,
you don't.
You don't care about them.
You're not charitable because you go and
you take a gun and you put it to
somebody's head and you say you will
make sure this fluid is clean.
But is there any evidence of a place
where that was scale?
Like before the FDA existed,
were there a lot of stores that were,
you know,
I don't think people are intentionally
poisoning tomatoes,
little grocer,
but is there any evidence that,
that it actually accomplished anything?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean,
the thing is,
is that it's all about the incentives.
Right?
So,
so the question is,
do you think that people are
incentivized to actually do good by
their community?
Because the way that capitalism works as
the better you serve your community,
the more they,
the more money you make.
Yeah.
Right.
But um,
but yeah,
there,
and there are always examples of,
you know,
just like there have been financial
panics before the Federal Reserve,
but somehow instead of having great,
you know,
instead of having great depression,
it's like we did post fed,
we have these little short term blips,
little panics that happened in a year.
It cleans itself out and it's gone.
But now what we do is government steps
in and any prolonged crisis,
right?
And exacerbates crisis because then you
have to have tax payer money spent on
the cleanup,
right.
Whereas before,
if there was like a food poisoning case,
right,
a local judge would have a judgment and
they would,
you know,
exact,
tribute and they would bring it back to,
you know,
whatever.
The,
uh,
the victims were,
you know,
and there would be just compensation for
that.
But again,
it comes down to the question of,
of whether or not you think that some,
you know,
bureaucracy in Washington DC
consensually plan all of the food and
all of the drugs everybody takes in the
United States.
I think it's Hubris to assume that a,
that people are smart,
right?
And Yeah,
you can get the best people in the
world,
you know,
and put them in a little room and
hopefully you're going to get some good
ideas.
But uh,
but more often than not,
it's again,
it's,
it's Hubris because they think that they
can possibly play all of our allies.
They can't.
The definition of socialism is,
is central planning central control over
our lives,
right?
Ninety percent income tax rate.
You have no choice.
The state plans,
everything.
And that's really the road to serfdom
essentially,
right?
It's a freedom is dangerous.
Freedom is dangerous as hell,
but I'll take her to stop poisoning our
tomatoes.
And by the way,
you know,
with all this inspector stuff,
of course,
first off you can pay off and an
inspector very easily.
There's so many little ways around it.
It reminds me a little bit when like
when I was a kid and I went to sleep
away camp and the date and the camp
would be like a disaster for three weeks
and we were like swimming in sewage the
day before visiting day when the parents
are coming.
They cleaned up the whole freaking
place.
Yeah.
And it looks good.
Parents come,
they're happy,
and then they leave.
Next thing you know,
next day we have license,
right?
But the difference between a private
inspector and a state inspector is that
if the at both both have a tendency to
be corrupt,
but you can't fire the state inspector.
It was going to take an election or it's
going to take,
you know,
some connections in DC.
Right?
But if you've got a private inspector,
then they are much,
uh,
they are much more tied to their
communities and uh,
and again,
you can fire them,
you can prosecute them and the
government will,
I will guarantee you he's going to step
in and clamped down on that.
But if it's the government and you're
trying to sue the state,
it's very difficult.
You briefly mentioned taxes,
let's do it.
Taxes is taxation theft.
It's more like extortion,
right?
But it doesn't make for as fun a slogan.
It doesn't feel that I have a great hat
that I,
that I sell.
It says make taxation theft again
instead of make America great again.
And that goes really well,
but I didn't want to wear it in
California because I thought they would
think it was a trump hat and I might get
beat up even if you just wear a red hat.
I know.
Did you see this?
I had a guy that hated abby a couple of
weeks ago that he wore.
He was wearing a nintendo switch hat,
the nude Nintendo and it's a red hat.
And he said people were telling him to
go fuck himself.
Come on.
Yeah.
Well and yeah,
somebody got beat up and I'm in DC
because it said a make bitcoin great
again,
or something like that.
The left has gone a little bit nuts,
I think,
as you've started to detail on some of
your videos,
but um,
when it comes to taxes,
a tax or the price we pay to live in a
civilized society.
Just kidding.
No,
like that.
You went to the camera,
triggered all the libertarians are
watching.
Um,
uh,
taxes should be as low as possible,
right?
The idea is that you should keep the
fruit of your labor.
That's the philosophical argument,
but the,
the technical argument is,
is the government wastes so much money.
They wasted money because they don't
have an incentive.
Right?
I have an incentive to save money,
but if we go out to dinner tonight,
Dave,
and you're like Austin and I'm taking
the finest restaurant in Los Angeles,
I'll be alright,
great.
I'm getting steak and lobster shrimp.
I'm going to get all the fixings.
Right?
And so there's no incentive for
government officials to save.
So there's no,
there's no incentive for them to be
careful stewards of the public's money
in our trust and they build these
budgets that they have to exceed.
Otherwise their budgets get slashed
because people,
they didn't use the mic.
I'll take it in and out,
but that's really all in and out a
secret menu though.
But yeah,
when it comes to taxes,
I,
I'm not a fan of the income tax just
because it assumes that the money isn't
yours.
Right.
It basically assumes that,
no,
this is our money and we're going to let
you have some of it as soon as we've
taken out our share.
Right.
Withholding.
And uh,
again,
from a philosophical perspective,
I think it's,
I think it's just anathema to the
concept of freedom.
We didn't have it before 19,
13.
Somehow the roads got built,
the roads did get built,
guys.
We had systems tariffs,
right?
But at least with a tariff system,
and I'm not a fan,
I'm not a fan of tariffs either,
but with a tariff system,
I mean you're in a sense you're paying
for what you use,
right?
It's kind of like Gary Johnson's,
you know,
national sales tax proposal.
Right now you're just paying for what
you use,
what you consume.
Which I think in some ways as a,
from a moral perspective,
I think it's better than an income tax,
which just says,
well,
what you have is ours and we'll let you
keep a little bit,
little part of it.
I prefer a flat tax system.
I know that's controversial because poor
people pay a larger percentage of their
goods and services,
uh,
of,
of their,
of their money into essential goods and
services.
So,
so there is a problem with that because
people say that's regressive and that,
and that is true.
And I acknowledged that.
But again,
if you really believe in true equality,
which we hear a lot from progresses,
if,
if we all,
if we want people to be equal in some
sense,
then shouldn't they be taxed at an equal
rate?
Well,
the then they disagree and they say no.
If you make more,
you should have to pay more.
And I think that that creates big word
here,
disequilibrium in the sense because
because the people who are the most
productive are,
are being harnessed the most,
right?
And the people who are the least
productive in some sense are paying
less,
right?
So if we're all,
and that's not to say that it should,
could,
should,
would,
what's moral here,
but in some sense you're,
you're taking the people who are
creating all of the wealth of society.
And this is the Randy and concept of,
you know,
here is that you're taking all those
people and you're disincentivizing the
cream of society.
And so I think that that's not the right
way to go about it.
You should.
Everybody should be taxed at the same
rate for,
to be taxed at all.
Um,
and most of the taxes that we have,
I,
you know,
I think are just excessive.
But,
uh,
you know,
again,
it's not just the income taxes,
sales taxes,
property taxes,
you know,
you've got fines and fees everywhere you
go.
Trust me,
I'm a business owner now and I just did
my taxes this week.
I know about a whole new slew of taxes I
didn't know about for the privilege of
sitting in your home during this
interview.
You have the government 15 percent.
Yeah,
it's unbelievable.
So,
so alright.
So you mentioned a flat tax and when
people asked me about taxes and I think,
you know,
I've said for awhile as a,
as a liberal,
I haven't moved,
I've,
I've watched the left go off the deep
end so it makes it seem like I'm more
right even though I don't,
I don't think I've moved,
but I think I've shifted a little bit on
taxes which is I would basically be for
some sort of flat tax.
I'm just gonna pick a number for a
second and we can go backward and that
let's say 15 percent flat tax and if you
made less than 50 grand you don't pay
any taxes because you need the help the
most and if you make over 10 million or
something like I would pick at something
pretty high.
You pay another two percent and then
maybe over $100 million to pay another
present.
But something like that.
Does something like that make some sense
to you?
Yeah,
I mean for any reform,
the tax system that we have,
I can be reasonable.
Right?
Like I may not like taxes at all right
there.
I just shout it from a,
from a just a simple like,
you know,
reaction,
I just despise taxes,
but um,
I think that it's time for us to have
some sort of reasonable tax reform.
So.
So yeah,
I think that these kinds of,
this is the kind of solution that I was
looking for.
The real problem is,
isn't with taxes,
it's worth spending because the spending
is just future taxes and we've gotten
ourselves to what,
$20,000,000,000,000
in debt.
I mean when I was a kid,
every the Conservatives and,
and what are the,
the Democrats were attacking the
conservatives in the Republican party
because Ronald Reagan drove up our
national debt to $144,000,000,000.
What is it now?
It's 20 trillion,
$144 million versus $20,000,000,000,000.
So we've gone into the twilight zone in
some sense in terms of our spending.
And we take into trillion a year.
We spent 4 trillion a year.
That to me is a,
is a recipe for disaster.
So it seems fairly obvious to me,
and I'm not an economist,
but we're never going to pay this money
back.
That seems obvious to me.
And that then unfortunately creates a
situation where it's why we need a
military.
You know what I mean?
That one day trying to,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I,
I don't,
that's just,
that just seems real world to me.
One day it's possible.
China is going to go,
whoa,
you guys are racked up quite a bill over
here.
Uh,
what are we going to do about that?
And then unfortunately we know we're not
gonna pay it back because we don't have
the money.
And that's how you ended up in another
war.
So in a bizarre way,
a debt brings war.
I think.
I mean,
the United States is defaulted before
and it didn't go to war.
I mean we had,
um,
the,
the Bretton Woods,
a crisis of course,
that we had where we finally closed the
gold window or no longer could you trade
dollars for gold internationally.
And then we did it nationally.
And in many ways,
this is a default because in some sense
you're destroying the savings of people
who had money back to buy gold.
And so these are,
these are defaults in a sense and,
and it,
it didn't cause war,
but in mean our,
our creditors overseas who wanted to be
able to exchange their dollars for gold,
you know,
they didn't attack us.
So I don't know that it necessarily
needs it.
It would necessarily lead to war,
but if we had a default in some sense.
But uh,
you know,
here's the thing,
I mean,
it's only $20,000,000,000,000,
right?
It's not 100,
$100,000,000,000,000
in the United States economy that we put
out $2,000,000,000,000
a year or two to $2,000,000,000,000
a year.
It wouldn't take that long for us to pay
it off if we would cut spending.
So.
So it's not that it's not feasible to
cut taxes because I think everybody
wants to cut taxes and everybody,
if you ask them,
would say,
can I pay a lower tax for the sandwich?
You know?
Yeah.
Well,
everyone says they'd like to cut them
for themselves,
but there's plenty of people that would
say I'd like them to be higher for sure.
Sure.
But if we could get some sort of broad
based tax form,
let's say we do stocking to solve the
problem because again,
any spending is just a future tax
increase,
but if we could cut spending and then
there are some proposals that have been
put out and I put one out in my
presidential campaign,
we called it the penny plan where rather
than try and kill elbow,
you know,
or,
or some special interests,
right?
You just make everybody take a haircut
from the top.
And it was called the penny plan because
you'd cut one penny out of every federal
dollar across the board.
Right?
And then you would put in a,
a,
you know,
a cap,
a spending cap,
so like 15 percent of GDP,
right?
So that you wouldn't,
you wouldn't spend yourself into
oblivion in the future.
Uh,
but I think that if you just give
everybody a little haircut across the
top and then you continue to do that
every year,
those savings start to add up and I
think that that's a reasonable way to do
it rather than inflame some,
the passions of the people who love pbs
or the National Park Service and things
like that.
If everybody has to take the same
haircut,
just like if we're all taxed the same.
Right?
I mean that's really a quality in a
sense.
Uh,
but it's,
again,
it's not necessarily politically
feasible,
but new ideas got to get them out.
Yeah.
So That's interesting.
And that's actually consistent with what
you said earlier about sort of
incremental things or how you would
change things without burning down the
system.
So in this case,
you're not taken big bird out to the
shed and shooting him,
but I would get a lot more facebook fans
by said that would be a lot more popular
because you know it right now,
as you know,
we could get in the media,
but I'll just tell you,
it's so polarized right now that,
you know,
if you're not with us,
you're against us.
If you're not a feminist,
you're a bigot.
If you're not a conservative,
then you're a stupid lip toward and,
and it's,
it's difficult to be.
I mean,
I don't,
I'm not a moderate,
right?
I'm a radical competitive admissions but
amongst,
but in the political world of today,
I mean,
you know,
I think I bore people because I come up
with such simple solutions and say,
okay,
this is a path towards,
uh,
towards what we really want.
And Progressives can get on board some
of these things,
right?
Gay Marriage,
you know,
liberal Liberals,
Democrats can get onboard those people
who even like Hillary or Bernie can get
on this.
And people who,
like Gary or whatever,
they're.
There are all sorts of solutions that I
think has a broad base of support
amongst the American people.
The people who control our politics
right now,
uh,
on,
on left,
right are so toxic that he poisoned the
well,
and that's why obamacare wasn't
overturned.
Not because the house freedom radicals
were in there,
but because the people who were in the
establishment,
we're,
we're slapping it together and they,
I mean,
in some sense they were the radicals
because they were doubling down on
obamacare in many ways and then they
start to demonize the opposition within
their own party and the Democrats are
just loving it.
But,
but,
but the Democrats have their own
problems too.
Right?
All right.
So let's throw away some easy ones.
So,
medical marijuana and legalizing
marijuana altogether.
No problem.
Sure.
About the problem with legalizing it is
that you got to pay taxes.
So,
I mean,
I guess,
you know,
decriminalizing is where the anarchist,
but uh,
but yeah,
I'll take legalization over.
Nothing.
Alright,
we'll throw that one away.
Gay Marriage,
not a problem,
right?
Two people want to do what they want.
No problem.
Can I,
can I talk about that for a second?
Let me just say that I just trying to
give you some easy ones to just love it.
But I am so happy whenever anybody finds
love,
you know,
and,
and it's just not set enough by people.
It's like,
what the hell business is it if somebody
else else's happy that the government
should get involved in a contract
between two consenting adults?
Yeah.
I just,
like,
I,
I never understood like I've seen on
some level where some people,
you know,
they find discussed with it.
I never,
I just never felt that way.
Right.
And um,
I have just way too many gay friends and
family members that,
uh,
that I've grown up around that I love
like crazy and I want them to be happy.
And so yeah,
when it comes to gay marriage,
it's not a gay marriage question.
It.
So does the state have have a prevailing
interest and telling people that they
can't sign a contract and that's how I
feel about it.
Yeah.
And that's why I've used that one as
it's such a consistent example of where
liberals and Libertarians can get
together,
so you may be a liberal who just feels
that this is the right thing to do and
the liberal thing to do and you may be a
libertarian even though you said Nice
things about,
about gay people and whatever,
but you may just be a libertarian.
He says,
I just don't want the government like
this now.
Conservatives and Alabama or pushing a
bill to get the state out of marriage,
now they're doing it because they are
absolutely tired of the government
stepping in and saying,
well,
we're forcing you to recognize gay
marriages.
Right?
And so we may actually get a consensus
on this because the conservatives are so
tired of losing these culture wars and.
Well,
the Democrats love winning.
But,
uh,
but I think that if we,
if we could get a consensus for it,
unfortunately now because of the,
the overfelt case,
which I still support,
but because of the overfill case,
it's now a federal issue,
right?
It's like abortion.
We just can't go back to a state based
solution on this,
but if we can get people to accept an
idea first that then we can start
talking about putting it action.
Yeah.
And I suspect as with abortion it's
going to just stay the way it is and I
don't think,
but that remains to be seen.
Uh.
Alright.
So I gave you two basically is the only
thing that we'll do to tougher ones that
we've sort of touched on here.
A second amendment.
So obviously I know you are a strong
supporter of the second amendment.
Are there any regulations that we should
have on gun?
Well,
maybe nukes,
right?
So maybe you shouldn't be able to have a
nuclear weapon,
right?
No,
no,
we don't want to.
Kim Jong Moon.
Okay.
That might be the,
the tipping point.
Everything.
But nukes for the most part.
The problem is that most people think
that if you,
if you make it legal to own tanks,
then like everybody's gonna own tanks.
Well it's not true because it's so
expensive to own a tank.
I it,
you can't even drive it down the 10 feet
without the gasoline,
the insane gasoline bill that it would
take.
And I was probably probably be illegal
to drive that on the road too,
so.
Right,
so you don't have to worry that people
are going to suddenly come out with
tanks and this is going to make some
people uncomfortable,
but you really need to understand that
the revolution was fought by in many
ways by militia men.
They,
they fought with military grade weapons
of their time.
And so I worry about disarming the
citizenry one day.
I mean,
liberals are now arming up by ultimate
irony now the liberals all are talking
about limits on executive power because
trump is in power and create,
you know,
all of their screams of misogynists and
racists.
And so now they're like,
well,
maybe we need to do about it.
Something about it.
One day they're talking about states
rights because the sanctuary cities,
I mean,
everything's upside down now.
Right,
right.
And,
uh,
and so there is some irony there in
that,
but hey,
if they agree with me,
great.
I saw some liberals were out like,
uh,
doing a,
a gun march the other day,
but then when we look closer they were
carrying airsoft.
You guys might want to get some actual,
some actual guns,
but yet strong from support of the
Second Amendment says arms for a reason.
Right.
So it's a bit of,
you know,
up to use the ideas is that,
the arms,
the definition of that would change.
Uh,
so I do think that citizens should be
able to have that fully automatic
rifles.
Like I want to live in a world where gay
married couples can defend their
marijuana fields,
fully automatic machine guns.
That's a beautiful world.
Think about it.
You're giving me a lot.
They're happily married lesbians who
grow marijuana and one day somebody
comes in and wants to steal their stash.
I mean,
they can do,
they should be able to grab their ones
and you know,
kick some ass.
Yeah,
that sounds like that should be on
Netflix,
that show,
you know,
I'm all right,
but somebody's gonna hear that and go,
all right,
I've been with this guy is making some
sense,
but I don't want my neighbor walking
around with a bazooka.
The tank is obviously okay.
You can't afford a tank,
but maybe a save 20 grand.
I don't know what you'd call it.
Right.
But you know what I mean?
So how do you stop the crazy person from
just saving all their money and buying a
weapon that they could blow up at school
or.
Well,
you could tell you could get on the
Internet and,
and uh,
you could build a bazooka for a lot less
than it costs to buy one because that's
probably not the answer they wanted to
do.
Probably not.
But that's the problem is,
is that people who want to do evil
things are going to do it,
right.
It's,
it's a,
it's very easy to make a gun,
you know,
you can take a pipe,
put a,
put a shotgun shell in it,
hit it with a hammer,
that's a gun.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
I,
I don't want to say that,
oh well we don't ban it ban something
simply because,
oh,
it's,
you know,
it's possible to do it right.
We banned murderer for,
for good reasons.
Uh,
but a gun is a tool,
right?
It's just a tool and it's just,
it's only as evil as the person who
wields it.
Like A,
an object in itself doesn't carry any
morality.
Like,
like,
uh,
sometimes libertarians would get upset
with me because I talk about drones for
example.
And I say,
well,
a drone is again,
just a tool.
It's just,
it's just like any other tool and it,
what matters is that constitutional due
process is applied when the government
uses a tool like this,
right?
We like drones much better than we like
carpet bombs,
right?
Because it's been more pinpointed.
Right?
But the ultimate question is,
is who wields the gun?
Who Will,
who has power to do it?
The finding is about liberals that kind
of kills me are the ones who are the
anti gun liberals,
is that they,
they say things like,
you know,
oh my God,
these cops are so evil and racist and,
and they hate,
they hate blacks but an only they should
own guns.
Right?
Well there,
I mean that goes to the heart of the
argument,
which is always how corrupt and evil the
system is.
What's the answer?
Make the system bigger.
I think this system bigger,
right?
Hire more cops.
Right.
And I,
I,
you know,
I don't usually get off on seeing people
get harmed,
but when you.
It was some irony in occupy Wall Street
and some of these definitions of people
calling for more government and then
they get government right in the face or
the pepper spray,
right?
You wanted more government and there it
is,
right?
That that is the ultimate result of the,
of the call for more state intervention.
So.
So there is some irony there when you
see,
when you see a leftist get bashed over
the head by,
by the police truncheon that that's
essentially what they're calling for
when they say we need more regulations,
we need higher taxes.
That's the state because as Mao Zedong
said,
you know,
all political power flows from the
barrel of a gun.
And so you have to be careful about the
use of power because it's,
it's fire,
it's forced,
it's not reason.
Yeah.
Abortion,
let's go.
Oh boy.
So I had a flip on this.
Not before way before I ever thought
about running for office.
And um,
because,
uh,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a secularist,
right?
I,
uh,
believe in empirical study and data and
science and things like that.
So I didn't have some sort of,
um,
some divine intervention that said,
Austin,
you know,
you need to believe this.
Right?
So,
but when I started to listen to some of
the secular prolifers arguments on this,
I was convinced people like Christopher
Hitchens,
and even bill Maher as has said at some
point to express some sympathy towards
the,
the unborn child.
Uh,
and so the question in my mind is,
is,
is it a life?
Is it a human life?
I think the answer to that question is
yes.
And then it gets down to the question
of,
well,
when does life begin?
Well,
can I be intellectually honest and say,
I don't know because I'm not a scientist
and that I don't know everything,
but if I'm to make a mistake,
uh,
I would probably think it would be.
The moral question is,
should you err on the side of life?
So I think that yes,
we should err on the side of life.
Um,
and uh,
this is,
this is not a scientific or empirical
question,
but my,
um,
my little sister is adopted and she was
slated to be boarded by her mother and
we convinced her not,
not to abort and then we adopted her.
And so I think to myself,
wow,
you know,
like I'm so glad that she's alive.
And I say then I think about all the
people who want children for adoptions.
Because while we were going through the
adoption process,
that was 11 years old,
but I was learning about the adoption
process and studying it and I realized
how many parents just really want
children.
So I think that it,
abortion for convenience is a problem
morally.
I think it's a problem because I think
that if you really,
if you really want to live in a moral
society,
we should encourage people to adopt.
It's not to say,
Oh,
you know,
you conservative or liberal prolife
libertarians only care about a baby once
it's born.
Right?
But that's not true because my family
adopted,
right?
I know many parents who are dying to
adopt children.
Um,
you know,
I'd like to have kids one day and if I
can't have kids I'm going to adopt.
So I think that,
you know,
again,
with knowing that this isn't a perfect
world and that,
you know,
we're never going to be able to just
completely ban it.
Like,
Venezuela tries to do that.
If that,
I think that we can probably agree that
abortion isn't a good thing.
Some people think it's a good thing,
but it's fetishized in a bizarre way,
but,
but I think most people don't think it's
a good thing.
Otherwise,
why is the stigma or the shame attached
to it?
But I think that if that's true,
I think science is going to come up with
new ways for us to,
to save the kids of the life of
children.
Um,
you know,
earlier and earlier perhaps that are
going to be some options there.
I know a lot of Catholic charities that
would spend millions of dollars to see
technology like that come to the light
of day.
So I think that that looking to the
future that abortion is probably going
to become less of a problem,
especially because birth control is
becoming so much more available.
And when it comes to the law,
the first things that I would like to do
when it comes to policy,
try and find the most non coercive way
to reduce the amount of abortions.
The number one simplest way that makes
some people very upset still is to just
legalize birth control over the counter.
And that's,
that comes part and parcel with ending
the war on drugs.
Um,
and so there some institutional
challenges there,
but I think that abortion is wrong.
I think that it is a human life.
I think that as a,
as a society that we should protect the.
If government is to exist,
then its role should be to protect those
who cannot protect themselves and I
think that that should include the
unborn.
Uh,
but of course we have federal challenges
to that and we have court challenges
with that.
We have stated challenges with that.
But I,
I try and make the moral argument
because unless we can win the moral
argument will never win the legislative
argument.
Yeah.
Well I liked the way you framed the
argument there because it's also nice to
occasionally hear someone say,
I don't know everything and you're not a
scientist.
And that there's an actual moral
quandary here.
What did you make of a couple of weeks
ago when Tomi Lahren came out and said,
you know,
that she,
using her conservative principles is
actually approach.
I don't know that she said she herself
was pro choice,
but she said that she didn't want the
government basically legislating what a
woman could do with her body.
I do see that as an intellectually
consistent a position.
It may not be the conservative position.
It may not be the position that that
Glenn Beck who I like and who's been
chair believes and he did what he did.
God shows no longer on the blaze.
That's a whole separate issue,
but do you think that there is
legitimacy to the argument?
No.
The.
The,
the first thing that popped into my head
was,
oh,
she's had an abortion because three
weeks before that she said,
I know there's a video from being a
complete hypocrite here.
So something happened.
That was my first thought.
Then I was like,
well,
you can't prove that,
and then I thought to myself,
okay,
so what is this really all about?
Well,
if the argument is,
is that the government has no prevailing
interest in getting involved in,
in a woman's body,
well then can the government save the
child if something's wrong with the
mother,
if she's in a coma,
can the,
can the government take the child out?
Let's say the,
let's say that the,
the situation happens where the mother
is life is actually in danger and the
mother,
but the mother can't give consent.
I mean,
can the nurse then save the life of the
Child?
But what if the mother at the time
doesn't want the child to be born?
What if she woke up and decided,
oh no,
I wouldn't actually want to have an
abortion.
Right?
What would the nurse probably not try
and save the life of the child by
default because she thinks of it as a
baby.
When beyonce posted pictures of her
being pregnant,
they,
the liberals were saying that,
oh,
those are babies.
Those are children.
Those are humans,
right?
But that,
but they're not babies.
They're not humans.
Uh,
but when it comes to the timing there
and thing,
I think she probably just says whatever
she can say to get traffic and clicks
and God knows I've been so tempted to
fall into her,
her example because you could make a lot
more money that way.
But,
um,
I think that when it comes to the
question of whether it's consistent or
not for,
for a government to intervene,
I mean even Gary Johnson who parades
himself around as a pro choicer signed a
partial birth abortion ban.
So a most abortions do occur within the
first trimester.
But,
but the real thing,
again,
when I said we're full circle here,
the most politically incorrect thing
that you can say is that you should be
personally responsible is that we have
things called condoms and birth control.
And you are supposed to take care.
Because the problem with the liberal
argument of freedom is,
is that I am free to not only,
you know,
destroy other people's lives and harm
and create harm and have the government
solve.
But I'm also free to self destruct and
to make you pay for it.
And a prime example of that is,
is the,
uh,
like for example,
when the Supreme Court upheld Obamacare,
I was there the day that happened,
the liberals were unironically smoking
cigarettes after it was over,
not because they were necessarily
addicted to nicotine.
It was a side to the rest of us that I
can do whatever I want and now you have
to pay for it.
And uh,
you know,
there are people who think that taxpayer
funded abortions should exist and that
we,
we should pay for those decisions.
But when it comes down to it,
if it is killing a child,
but it's killing a human child,
well,
shouldn't you be personally responsible?
Shouldn't you have been careful
beforehand?
And then you know,
you've got the questions of rape and all
these other things that come into it,
which is always like a t,
you know,
we'd like to take tiny,
tiny exceptions to rules and then blow
them out and conflict to the rules.
But again,
I don't know everything and the
government cannot possibly legislate
from Washington DC,
all of these problems.
Which is why I think it should be a
state issue because I think from an
administrative question,
uh,
the state should be allowed to
laboratories of democracy in some way,
right when it comes to the war on drugs,
when it comes to abortion,
right?
Like if you're in Texas,
if the war on drugs was ended federally,
Texas might execute you for looking at a
joint.
I'm here in California.
It may be like they may have,
you know,
you can execute you for not smoking or
not smoking.
Right.
So,
so that's the thing is that there are
some problems with federalism,
but I think when it comes to issues,
especially with life and death,
that those things are better handled the
close to the,
the smaller,
the tighter knit,
the community so that it's,
it's so that the,
the negative externalities aren't
projected on the rest of this because I
certainly don't think I should be
funding abortions.
Right.
I think that,
that,
that if I think it's a crime,
then I certainly should not be taxed to
do that.
It's just such a place where there's so
much richness for conversation where we
can find people that are perfectly moral
and just view things a little bit
differently because I do get the Tommy
argument there of keeping the government
out of it and I,
I personally am pro choice but um,
but I find great pleasure in it at all
and I have all sorts of issues with,
you know,
later term abortions and stuff like
that.
Um,
but this,
this is one of those ones that it's
just.
Yeah,
but we make a mistake if we looked at
Tommy for intellectual stimulation,
that is an a and I hope she'll be here
so that I can ask her about that.
Um,
all right,
last question.
And I already told you what it was.
So a 20,
20.
We're doing this.
No.
Um,
I,
I don't like running for office.
Um,
I,
I really despise it.
And um,
as libertarian I really liked my
personal life.
Now I have looked at,
people have said Austin go run for lower
office.
And so I have looked at potentially
running in Missouri for Senate seat.
I've still got about a two or three
months before I have to decide some of
something like that,
but maybe,
you know,
I ran for president because of the
timing and because I thought that there
just weren't that many good people who
represented my beliefs.
And so I did.
I didn't run last year just because I
wanted to be the king of the United
States.
I ran because I thought that that Donald
and Hillary were so distasteful and Gary
was not the strongest candidate that
maybe I would look good by default and
you know,
could get our ideas out there.
And so,
and so,
um,
I think I,
in some ways,
you know,
I didn't win the presidency,
but in many ways I won the argument in a
lot of ways.
Look at retrospectively because a lot
more people are now interested in
libertarian ideas,
which is one of my goals.
Um,
but when it comes to running for
president in 20,
20,
I'm going to respectfully decline at
this time and say that maybe it would be
better for me to try and do something at
this point.
That would not be an altruist perhaps,
but,
but try and do something,
give something back to the citizens of
my state who have got a horrible
senator,
Claire mccaskill,
Democrat,
who's now for complete partisan
politics.
She should kind of shooting yourself in
the foot saying she's going to
Filibuster Neil gorsuch and uh,
and she's doing this because she's
terrified of the progressives in our own
party.
Uh,
the Bernie Bros and all that,
or they're threatened threatening to
primary or so now she's being pushed so
hard to the left.
She's going,
you know,
doing what Hillary did,
the mistakes and Hillary made going hard
left as you can,
hoping that those socialists and Social
Democrats are going to push her into it.
But if I think that there is an opening
there to maybe run for Senate in
Missouri Than,
than I might pursue that.
But,
but God,
I don't know.
I see what's happening to trump on a
daily basis.
And I,
you know,
I don't really have that much of a lust
for power.
So yeah,
at this point,
and we see the inherent problem with all
of this.
Good principled people simply don't want
to be part of this game anymore.
So you're left with it.
Well,
you know,
it destroys you,
right?
So it's,
you know,
every little personal thing that you've
ever said,
right?
Every job,
every off color joke that you've ever
made,
say suddenly used to demonize you.
I mean,
I thought it was a good person until
last night.
I didn't realize that as a sexist,
misogynist,
and all of these things.
And uh,
but then when you look at it,
it's like the truth is who is fit to
rule?
Nobody's really fit to rule over all of
us and the,
and the power.
It has so much power.
I mean,
I just,
um,
at this point I'm going to save me.
I don't really have an interest in.
All right,
well,
you put it on the record.
So now if you do end up running for
whatever reason,
you're going to be considered a flip
flop.
But they always do that to everybody.
Like Donald Trump said,
no,
I'm not going to run for president.
And he runs for president,
right?
It always does.
But you know,
on the,
on the minuscule chance that you know,
that I feel like I can see I'm called to
public service,
which is what it should be.
Then maybe there's an opportunity,
but at this point,
you know,
I've got a lot of other things that I
really need to focus on my own personal
life,
you know,
like maybe have kids someday,
you know.
Alright.
Well as I told you before we started,
people email me every day asking if I'm
going to do it.
I don't want to run for president,
but if I do,
would you at least help me before the
debates because you know your shit.
Yeah.
What is Aleppo Limbo is.
That's like half of it.
Would you make them bake the cake?
No,
I would not make them bake the cakes.
He thought that we haven't gotten to
this.
We said okay,
let's go real quick.
Alright.
We'll let you know.
We're gonna do this for our bonus
segment after we'll do the cake thing
because people know my feelings about
the case.
Alright,
I will.
I've thoroughly enjoyed this and for
more on often follow them on
facebook.com/producer
Peterson s e n.